hey guys mark lawyer here time to update
you guys again on what's been going on
with the channel first off the money for
the best friends charity that we did
back in September has finally been sent
I finally got to hell with that money
it's totaled two forty six thousand two
hundred and fourteen dollars and eighty
one cents including my contribution of
two thousand five hundred dollars and
the money for the Cincinnati Children's
Hospital has been I believe or at least
to them if not released already it will
be in the very near future in that was
fifty five thousand three hundred and
eleven dollars no seventy seven dollars
for that charity which brings our grand
total for the past year and some change
that we've been doing live streams up to
two hundred and seven thousand dollars
two hundred and two hundred seven
thousand two hundred and twenty one
dollars all for charity so sincerely
thank you guys so much that's that's
absolutely incredible because at the
beginning of this year my goal was to
raise fifty thousand dollars for charity
and I knew that we could do that I just
didn't know how much we would surpass it
by so sincerely thank you guys so much
for everything that you've done there
won't be another charity event in
December or at the end of this month's I
feel like I've been asking a lot of you
guys and I want to figure out some way
to pay you back so I'm gonna think of
something some way to give you guys back
what you have given so much for me in
December I'm gonna try to do a giveaway
of some sort stay tuned for that if you
got any suggestions for what you want me
to do write it in the comments below or
write it on Facebook or Twitter or
whatever you got other than that there
has once again been outstanding progress
on the growth of this channel we hit a
million subscribers about two and a half
weeks ago and we're already pushing
almost another hundred thousand out of
here we got I think we're at a million
sixty one thousand saying that number is
ridiculous because it's just I I never
imagined I'd get here so being here and
be able to say it is just really really
weird for me but I'm sincerely grateful
another reason why I want to give back
to you guys for giving me and supporting
me through all your efforts in charity
and on supporting the channel I really
owe you guys everything so I need to
make sure that you know you guys feel
appreciated for what cuz I'm one guy I
can't go individually if I could go each
to one of you and shake your hand and
say thank you
give me a hug or something I'd do it but
you know I have just one guy he Ohio
can't do much so stay tuned for more of
that there definitely is gonna be some
in the future but right now I'm very
happy to say that drunk minecraft is
back and in full swing Bob finally got
some free time I don't know how long
it'll last but we've been able to do a
recording session about once every other
week and we've been able to get it quite
a few videos out there so far the
response have been great I mean it's
always been you know some people don't
like minecraft and I can perfectly
understand that but it is what I
consider my personal series and one of
my funniest series that I've ever done
and I really am glad that as such a
following and such support so if you
haven't seen it yet it's not organized
in season 3 I just kind of mishmash to
everything in a one big playlist so
everyone could see the whole history of
drunk minecraft if you wanted to it's
seriously a funny series it has its
moments where it's not as funny just
where it drags on a bit but that's cuz
it's just long uncut episodes so thank
you guys everyone who supported me in
them thank you for having patience until
we got this series back because I really
wanted to get it back
introducing this stuff like that um
since we had a million subscribers I
really want to put more effort into the
videos that I make and not just in
gaming videos or stuff like that I
really want to make this channel more
than just about videogames or something
like you guys know that I've always
wanted to do sketch comedy video that's
what I wanted to do before I started
this channel and I'm not gonna stop
doing as many videos does that happen
doing I upload about two to three videos
a day more on the two side than the
three side moment to try to get to the
three again but I want to also have this
channel be sort of this hub for all
sorts of entertainment that you guys can
really get enjoy I mean you guys have
really been liking the sketch comedy
videos that I've been doing with cyndago
and I've got some more stuff in store
that I'm gonna work on with Wade and
other people in the Cincinnati area
other friends of mine that I wanna that
you either already know about some of
you maybe but you know I want to get
more people involved in making really
high production quality
maybe slapstick humor but hopefully
entertaining stuff nonetheless because I
want to branch out and do more
professional video production stuff and
remember
the is it's not gonna impact anything in
any way it's not gonna impact how many
videos they release for the gaming
videos that you love I'm just gonna try
to make the entertainment that I provide
to you more entertaining
that's just more it's my idea of just do
more and not do less got it got it okay
good now the last thing that I want to
talk to you about is um before I you
step goals you know going up from one to
ten thousand ten thousand one hundred
hundred to a million
I had these goals and we've smashed each
and every one of them over and over and
over again we cannot stop smashing them
so I feel like for the next goal that I
set for this channel it has to be pretty
darn high or else we're Network we're
gonna smash it way too soon if I said 2
million in the year I know we'd get
there way before now so I'm gonna really
reach for this next one if we can get
and today is November oh god what day is
today today is November 11th if we can
get this is a big number if we can get 5
million subscribers by November 11th of
2014 we will hit our new goal that is
the new goal but once again I can't get
there without your help it's all up to
you guys for helping the channel grow by
sharing the videos spreading the word
about the channel tell them what we do
for the charity efforts tell them what
we do for the entertainment that I
provide and remind them that this is all
for a big community that I love I love
this community to death and there's
gonna be some cool stuff to help make
this community more close-knit and it
helped me communicate with you guys I
mean I've been playing around on the
world Warcraft server that we're playing
on that livestream and it's just been
it's been fun to be able to just kind of
dick around with the guys that are there
or guys and gals and enter some dungeons
and stuff like that so I want more than
that though I'm working on getting a
website set up and get some forums up
there and I'm working with maker studios
and hopefully there's gonna be something
really cool maybe not this year but next
year there's gonna be a really cool hub
site for all of us to go to and really
communicate in so that's what's in store
and I really hope that we can get there
sooner rather than later but once again
it all rides on you
guys's shoulders um but oddly enough the
faster that we grow the more prioritize
my website gets for the company so if
you guys can help out in whatever
whatever way you can I mean I know you
guys already do it already because the
growth has to spend tremendous ever
since we hit a million in and I
appreciate it so much guys you guys have
done an amazing job that and sincerely
thank you for everything that you've
done for me but if we can hit 5 million
in another year well I'll just have to
set another goal that Mon I so sincerely
thank you guys so much for your undying
support I will be doing these vlogs more
regularly in the future I won't miss it
and if from lets they do and then sorry
apologize in advance so anyway that's
all I got for this episode thank you all
so much for watching thank you guys for
all your support and everything that you
do and as always I will see you in the
next video